tu voudrais de la lumière dans mon
jardin
transformer son jardin d'hiver pour le
printemps première étape son gazon pour
lui redonner un petit coup de verre un
peu d'engrais on va se créer des lignes
droites dans notre gazon c'est là bas
c'est le geste auguste du semeur le
paysagiste effectué deux passages un
premier par ligne puis dans la
perpendiculaire
cela permet une répartition homogène et
d'éviter la catastrophe
la brûlure de sa pelouse une opération a
effectué fin février et a renouvelé en
septembre pour un meilleur entretien on
voit un gazon qui repart quand même bien
il n'y a pas trop de nous parce que il
ay là il a ces deux apports d'engrais
par an
et pourtant on est on est un endroit où
on a une terre argileuse
si la terre argileuse du bassin et du
noah n'est pas des plus propices aux
jets que je vous
elle est en revanche idéal pour les
arbustes n'hésitez pas à leur faire de
la place dans vos massifs mais avant
plantation on l'habille sont arbustes à
billets c'est le retail et légèrement
avant la plantation pour qui les maîtres
du bois et de la racine
une fois ces branches mortes coupe et on
peut le sortir de son pot pour vérifier
et déployer légèrement ses racines en
blanc voyez c'est un végétal qui se
porte très bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
les radicelles c'est à dire les
nouvelles racines et à partir de ce
moment là une présence importante de
radicelles c'est clair buste il est prêt
à s'installer et il va partir très
rapidement lorsque vous creusez une
astuce créer une cuvette pour faciliter
l'arrosage si on fait pas cette cuvette
l'eau va tomber et restera jamais au
contact de de la plante
l'idée c'est vraiment d'amener le lot à
la racine l'idéal pour une nouvelle
plantation est un arrosage deux fois par
semaine de l'équivalent d'un seau d'eau
pour sa toute première tétée laplante a
même besoin d'un arrosage jusqu'au refus
il faut attendre ce phénomène pour pour
considérer que l'arrosage est bien
réalisé enfin n'oubliez pas vos plantes
qu'il faudra battre comme ceux romarin
qui a besoin de petites coupes
vous pouvez toujours l'égard des pros
vote premier barbecue de l'année